okay so we're going to get to the reason
we're all here first I'm going to read
the citation and then the winter
definition citation ok this is the
Pulitzer Prize for public service for a
distinguished example of meritorious
public service by a newspaper or new
site through the use of this
journalistic resources including stories
editorials cartoons photographs graphics
videos databases multimedia or
interactive presentations or other
visual material and the winner is the
Philadelphia Inquirer forest exploration
of pervasive violence in the city
schools using powerful print narratives
and videos to illuminate crimes
committed by children against children
and to store reforms to improve safety
for teachers and students Philadelphia
Inquirer
Oh
I just have to add something that Mike
Leary who was an editor on this project
for the Enquirer is a graduate of the
journalism school his parents were
graduates in 1947 and his
great-grandparents were graduates in
1917 so this is on the 100th anniversary
of the journalism school just wanted to
note that this is the Pulitzer Prize for
breaking news reporting for a
distinguished example of local reporting
of breaking news that as quickly as
possible captures events accurately as
they occur and as time passes
illuminates provides context and expands
upon the initial coverage the winner is
the Tuscaloosa Alabama news
for
force enterprising coverage force
enterprising coverage of a deadly
tornado using social media as well as
traditional reporting to provide
real-time updates to help locate missing
people and produce in-depth print
accounts even after power disruption
forced to paper to publish at another
plant 50 miles away congratulations
okay all right okay so we have two
prizes for Investigative Reporting Tom
you one on that one inside joke for a
distinguished example of investigative
reporting using any available tool
journalistic tool and winner of the
first prize is the Associated Press Matt
Apuzzo Adam Goldman Eileen Sullivan
Chris Hawley of the associated press for
their spot lighting of the New York
Police Department's clandestine spying
program that monitored daily life and
Muslim communities resulting in
congressional calls for federal
investigation and a debate over the
proper role of domestic intelligence
reporting congratulations to the
Associated Press
and our second prize in that category
again for a distinguished example of
missing one I'm sorry for a
distinguished example of investigative
reporting using any available
journalistic tool and our second winner
is Michael barons and Ken Armstrong of
the Seattle Times for their
investigation of how a little-known
governmental body in Washington State
moved vulnerable patients from safer
pain control medication to methadone a
cheaper but more dangerous drug coverage
that prompted statewide health warnings
congratulations to the Seattle Times
this is the Pulitzer for explanatory
reporting for a distinguished example of
explanatory reporting that illuminates a
significant and complex subject
demonstrating mastery of the subject
lucid writing and clear presentation
using any available journalistic tool
and the winner is David coach in esky I
hope I pronounced that right of the New
York Times for his lucid series that
penetrated a legal thicket to explain
how the nation's wealthiest citizens and
corporations often exploit loopholes and
avoided taxes congratulations to David
this is the prize for local reporting
for a distinguished example of reporting
on significant issues of local concern
demonstrating originality and community
expertise using any available
journalistic tool and the winner is Sara
Ganim and members of the patriot-news
staff in harrisburg pennsylvania for
courageously revealing and adeptly
covering the explosive penn state sex
scandal involving former football coach
Jerry Sandusky congratulations to Sara
in the team
and this is the price for national
reporting for a distinguished example of
reporting on national affairs using any
available journalistic tool the winner
is david wood of the huffington post for
his riveting exploration of physical of
the physical and emotional challenges
facing American soldiers severely
wounded in Iraq and Afghanistan during
the decade of war David congratulations
and the price for international
reporting the citation is as follows for
a distinguished example of reporting on
international affairs using any
available journalistic tool the winner
is Geoffrey government of the New York
Times
for his vivid reports for his vivid
reports often at personal peril on
famine and conflict in East Africa a
neglected but increasingly strategic
part of the world congratulations David
and the prize in feature writing goes as
follows for a distinguished example of
feature writing giving prime
consideration to quality of writing
originality and concision using any
available journalistic tool and the
winner this year is Eli Sanders of the
stranger as Seattle Weekly for his
haunting story of a woman who survived a
brutal attack that took the life of her
partner using the woman's brave
courtroom testimony and the details of
the crime to construct a moving
narrative Eli congratulations
for distinguished commentary using any
available journalistic tool and the
winner is Mary sneak of the Chicago
Tribune
for her wide range of down-to-earth
columns that reflect the character and
captured the culture of her famed city
of Chicago Mary congratulations
for distinguished criticism using any
available journalistic tool the winner
is Wesley Morris of the Boston Globe for
his smarts and then affirmed criticism
distinguished by pinpoint prose and a
easy traverse between the art house and
the big screen box office Wesley
congratulations
for a distinguished cartoon or portfolio
of cartoons characterized by originality
editorial effectiveness quality of
drawing and pictorial effect published
as they still drawing animation of both
the prize for editorial cartooning goes
to mark worker of the political Oh Matt
I'm sorry Mack
four is consistently fresh funny
cartoons especially memorable for
lampooning the partisan conflict that is
engulfed Washington apologize for that
and the prize for breaking news
photography for a distinguished example
in black and white or color which may
consist of a photograph or photographs
the prize goes to Massoud Hassani of a
juice france-presse did I do that right
clothes for his heartbreaking manage of
a girl crying in fear after a suicide
bombers attack at a crowded shrine in
Kabul thank you
for a distinguished example of feature
photography and black and white or color
which may consist of a photograph or
photographs the winner is craig walker
from my own denver post for his
compassionate chronicle of an honorably
discharged veteran home from iraq and
struggling with a severe case of
post-traumatic stress and images that
enable viewers to better grafts the
national issue congratulations Greg
now we move to the arts for the price in
drama for a distinguished play by an
American author preferably original and
a source in dealing with American life
the winner is water by the spoonful by
Kiera Allegra hoodies an imaginative
play about the search for meaning by
returning Iraq war veteran working in a
sandwich shop in his hometown of
Philadelphia Kiera
for the prize in history for
distinguished and appropriately
documented book on the history of the
United States Malcolm X a life of
reinvention by the late Manning Marable
is an exploration of the legendary life
and the provocative views of one of the
most significant african-americans in US
history a work the separate fact from
fiction and blends the heroic and tragic
accepting on behalf of Professor marable
this is Widow professor leaf mullings
who will accept the award welcome
the prize for biography for a
distinguished and appropriately
documented biography or autobiography by
an American author George F Keenan and
american life by john lewis gatos is our
winner an engaging portrait of a
globe-trotting diplomat whose
complicated life was in a woven with the
Cold War and America's emergence as the
world's dominant power mr gattis here
please come up
the prize in poetry for a distinguished
volume of original verse by an American
author life on Mars by Tracy k smith is
a collection of bold skillful poems
taking readers into the universe and
moving them to an authentic mix of joy
and pain Tracy Smith
for general nonfiction for distinguished
and appropriately documented book of
nonfiction by an American author that is
not eligible for consideration in any
other category the winner this year is
to swerve how the world became modern by
Stephen Greenblatt a provocative book
arguing that an obscure work of
philosophy discovered nearly 600 years
ago changed the course of history by
anticipating the science and
sensibilities of today professor green
black couldn't be with us but his editor
Elaine Mason will accept the award
Elaine
and finally for the prize of music for a
distinguished musical composition by an
American that has had his first
performance of recording in the United
States during the year Kevin putts for
silent night opera and two acts
commission and premiered by the
Minnesota Opera Minneapolis on November
12 2011 is a stirring opera that
recounts the true story of a spontaneous
ceasefire among Scottish French and
Germans during World War one displaying
versatility of style and cutting
straight to the heart a libretto by mark
Campbell danke
congratulations
over to you thank you greg did an
excellent job of pinch-hitting for a
president Bollinger now if you can just
issue bonuses to all the deans and
professors on his behalf we'd appreciate
it ladies and gentlemen I want to thank
you on behalf of the Pulitzer Prize
board for attending our award
celebration all the work of the winners
can be found on our website ww-p oh it's
org the next few days we will also be
posting a gallery of pictures and video
of the talks that were given today
finally I'll ask asked the winners to
please assemble on the steps up here at
the end of the program so we can get the
group graduating picture of this year's
Pulitzer winners it's always one of the
highlights so once again thank you for
coming and then congratulations once
again to all of our winners